this is Startalk this is Startalk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist I work at the
American Museum of Natural History in
New York City where I serve as the
director of the Hayden Planetarium and
I've got in studio with me
Chuck Chuck nice hey man welcome back
it's always good to be here Neil you
know we don't have a guest today so that
usually means what it usually means that
we're going to do some cosmic queries
ozma queries yes questions drawn from
our listenership in all of our social
media that's correct and I think what
happens is we solicit the questions and
sometimes questions don't fit in any
category right as they all just pop you
read don't worry I know what that means
but potpourri
it means none of these questions stink
yes that's it's cosmic queries potpourri
edition we're not Anna questions stink
I've not seen any other question no you
have not and which is not like a test is
no no yeah you're here to stop me but I
don't know the answer I'll go tell you
the answer exactly so let's get start
right off and it's very cool so uh this
is Brian marude I'm hoping I'm saying
you know why you have such issues you
people's names you know what it's become
with you it's actually become a thing
because people now are online they're
just like I just want to see how Chuck
butchers my name I can't wait to see
Harry Smith that went Mary Snyder
alright anyway so Brian marude I hope
Brian that's your name yeah this is what
Brian says I've seen a lot of
infographics lately about ripples in
space-time due to gravity are there any
space-time fabric waves caused by the
expansion of the universe or does the
concept of galaxies accelerating away
from each other a misnomer in that
they're not actually accelerating
through space so much as the space
between galaxies is getting bitter
bigger at an accelerated rate this guy's
been thinking man
yeah he's been thinking uh he's correct
okay next question
hello questions like that yes Daniel
Bryan not the answer is yes about that
yeah that's a comma 42 yes no the
gravitational waves are ripples within
the pre-existing fabric of space and
time and you can get these waves if you
have galaxies colliding or black holes
coalescing and you get Titanic
gravitational events in the universe
will trigger ripples through the fabric
of space-time and recall those gravity
waves and we right now we're trying to
detect them the laser interferometric
gravity wave Observatory LIGO like LIGO
Li Gao you can just like Geo you can
just Google that right as this is our
first attempt to detect these gravity
waves first predicted by Albert Einstein
now if those gravity waves were
interconnecting would that be Lego Lego
oh I'm just like if you can snap them
together build yourself a little gravity
wave past so I'll get back to you on
that so uh so when your things within
the pre-existing space can generate
gravity waves but space itself baseband
yeah yeah but that's expanding or there
may be a way but not by stuff that's it
something outside of something so there
has to be an event and if a cause is
this right because the gravity field is
there all the time something has to put
a ripple in it and that ripple moves by
the way at the speed of light oh I'm
sorry I had to put my hand up in front
of a camera there's a camera here now
anyway
uh it makes perfect sense it's a ripple
just like in a lake or a pond
you need something to drop into the
water to break the surface tension to
cause the way yeah and the pond is there
was without the ripple right want to put
in a ripple in observe that boom god
bada bing bada bing bada boom there you
go Bryan down by the way we haven't
detected a gravity wave yet this is a
very rare ways are very weak even when
they're strong they're weak no these
gravity wave detectors are going to
detect a disturbance over a given length
of space okay
that is about the same magnitude as the
width of an atomic nucleus we yes just
insane completely freakin insane
that's a frontier of Technology the
scientific question is pushing the
engineering frontier absolutely to make
this measurement and it that's what the
eye and LIGO the laser laser
interferometric gravity wave observatory
right and we're looking for graduates
and if we get good at it
we can detect gravitational disturbances
arising from the Big Bang itself wow
that's pretty cool excellent look at
that man that's so it's a it's
technology well it's actually it's an
answer in search of technology oh nice
perfectly it's a cancer in search of
technolo I'm gonna tell the organ I'm
gonna tell the folks who write the
brochures besides I was that famous
astrophysics if you only knew mmm hi hey
Brian oh man that was a very good
question thank you for chiming in my
friend okay this is Arthur Columbo
durante Duarte okay here's his question
and by the way you'll like this uh
Arthur says cheers from Brazil so he's
writing this from rusty rusty rusty but
he does not tell us we're just you know
it's a big place anyway he says what do
we know about the Great Attractor and
what are your thoughts on what it is or
could be could it be some sort of God
manner planet mmm interesting so the
people doing their homework from
gathered brightenings question a really
are they okay so mentally the couple of
decades ago it might have been in the
late 80s okay they're in the research of
where all the galaxies are going there
was a research paper that noticed that
there's an entire community of galaxies
that are all headed towards one spot
okay in space and then you look in that
spot in space and there's not an obvious
thing to be tugging on them yes and so
it became to be known as the Great
Attractor
and you expect things to be moving
because we're near each other will feel
each other's gravity we hold up those
are called peculiar velocities it turns
out not because they think peculiar
about them just if you're moving within
the fabric of space that's a very
natural speed that you would have so we
found that something called a great
attractor that's what it got called then
it got a lot of press in its day now
I've read up on the latest on that but
we know that there's dark matter
everywhere dark matter it has gravity
just like ordinary matter right and
there is six times as much of it so
we're no longer as shocked when we see
things being drawn to one part of the
universe or another right just because
we don't see anything they have anything
they're fully lit galaxies or anything
because we know that that happens yeah
you can have now can't be a dark matter
planet not likely I'll tell you why cuz
to make a planet matter whatever it is
that makes the planet has to be able to
stick to itself gotcha think about that
right right right what with all the
molecules of the rocks they're stuck to
one another all right Dark Matter not
only doesn't stick to our kind of matter
it doesn't even stick to itself okay so
it's not obvious how you would ever
coalesce dark matter into any kind of
solid object at all god yeah it was a
pass-through it has to itself so it's
not gonna it's not going to get together
and and hang out and be the evil other
planet are excised that's right is there
a dark matter earth and where you have a
goatee oh wait you have a goatee now
okay so my dark matter earth is a good
shot mmm interesting yeah that's very
cool so it's like it's like what's it
called here on earth and there's a place
in the ocean where all the floating
pollution tends to gravitate just read
about that and it just comes into this
giant trash circle trap mat M plastic
man and it's just a big massive um you
know swirl of plastic garbage okay that
has nothing to do with dark matter the
universe but it's still interesting that
that happens at all yeah but I'm saying
like this is like that for spam Oh hope
so that's a that's an attractor
attractor of itself oh yeah even if you
know yeah even though that's really just
ocean currents coming yeah yeah I'm you
know Councilman Ted tooling it's one
little place no
to let us know that we're a bunch of
a-holes polluting our world yeah that's
very cool so no Dark Matter planet
extremely extremely unlikely right okay
cuz evasion was everything we don't know
yeah about dark matter that pass to
herself nothing to stick it's gotta
stick to itself and then you pick you
make solid objects yeah but the
attractor itself completely
understandable because we know now yes
that dark matter had a rabbity just like
regular matter hey that's how we know
it's there hey Arthur man
another great question and people are
really living up to the potpourri
potpourri alright okay hmm
this is Mary flick flick hon Lacan okay
uh Mary doesn't tell me where she's
coming from
Mary says I want to know more about the
comment Ison
mm-hmm how close did it get to the Sun
and how did it survive its trap I guess
it might but I confess I just had a
hunch I guess I guessed it might but I
confess I had a hunch in other words she
she knew it would survive uh but comets
have been around a long time and seemed
to survive anything
oh that is so not the case yeah comet
Ison was a comet discovered a couple of
years ago and it was going to it was
heralded as the great Christmas comet it
was a comment that was on it back on the
on the back end as it neared it comes
around the other side of the Sun let's
remind ourselves
comets have very elongated orbits way
they spend a lot of time far away from
the Sun and a little bit of time very
close to the Sun these are strongly
elliptical orbits that's why you don't
see them all the time right will see
them when they visit right they pay the
inner solar system of this in turn right
comet Ison if you plotted its trajectory
it would come extremely close to the Sun
I don't remember exactly how close but
close like within a Suns own diameter
lots of it yeah yes yes yes that's
absolutely very very close yes yes yes
oh okay so now okay so yeah and and the
Sun is big ball of plasma and ha hot
comet is ice and cold
and you were looking at me like hey you
don't get these two right you're not
coming back after all this time here
shucks if you don't get these two it's
curtains a comet is cold and now you
want to bring the comet with in one
solar diameter of itself this this and
this is not bode well for the comment is
that so guess who's coming to dinner if
the comet had survived the other side
right it would have come out with a
beautiful long tail because the Sun
evaporates it actually Sublime's the
frozen getting of the frozen eye the
ices turns them into gases and on the
other side was Thanksgiving and
Christmas and it would have been a
beautiful comment and people were
touting it and talking it up and and but
nope the Sun tore a new one in that
comet had its way the Sun tore a new one
their images of this the Comets going in
with all perfectly shaped tail I saw
there's an acronym for an international
observation network or something it's an
accurate forgive me I don't have it off
the top of my head that's okay but it
came out the other side and it was a
raggedy looking thing the thing broke
apart it diffused and just completely
disappeared on the other side what will
the galling part I did probably debris
there but no longer was there a comment
for us to embrace that is us oh man yes
oh yeah the Sun tore new one that was
the end of the comment then there was no
and that all happened like on
Thanksgiving Day alright so yeah and
there was no Christmas comments so I saw
it came in and the stone was like this
is ma ha ha look up to God
don't do this to me a mouse every
comment no matter how close it comes
what a tail gets made it's actually
losing some of its own material
of course we're so comets have finite
lifetimes thank you if they can't go
around the Sun forever right
so yes so it doesn't make a difference
which comet that and so now eventually
eventually any comments going to die and
in fact you've heard of you know every
night if you look hard long enough
you'll find a meteor right chorus tuning
star and occasionally there are meteor
showers right which are always at the
same time each year you don't meteor
showers are that that is earth Oh
bowing through the debris stream of
long-dead comments awesome whose
trajectory crossed the orbit of the
earth Oh see now that is why they happen
at the same time every year okay and
that's why they're a higher rate of
these debris particles than in any other
random night so I song I have to check
which ways trajectory actually came
right whether that will become a new
meteor shower because we may one day
actually plow through the rightest of
ice on the rocky flux them and jetsam of
ice on right yeah yeah yeah you have to
check your for sport if the orbit has to
be sort of near the plane of our orbit
and then it's a whole brand new meteor
shower so a meteor shower is basically a
comet graveyard yeah exactly oh that's
awful yeah it's the crap left over after
the Sun done did its thing
oh wow wow that's a great great question
another one all right let's uh let's see
if we can get one more in here um before
brick yeah before the break here we go
alright here's a I don't know I'm gonna
put this in here cuz this this is from
Gerald gerald and Gerald this is a real
question from Gerald okay girls what
your wants to know go uh Chuck always
ask your new them okay I can sit this
one out
no uh how do you know you'll be asking
me the question I don't know I ask a lot
of questions to use them okay all right
dawn uh is Neil jacked or are his shins
just really tight my shins well you know
like you you there are pictures where
you have like you know oh look like your
your shirts I'm sorry your shirts the
wrestle hands oh let me do it again all
right get it back to two minutes
two-minute warning get back to two
minutes okay
I said shins yes Oh God Dubey t-shirt
did we teach him how to read before he
came on the show all right here we go
all right so this is from Gerald Durrell
Gerald is a real person so I'm going to
ask this but it says Chuck
is Neil Jack or are his shirts just
really tight well first uh uh now in my
day yeah I was jacked yeah I was gonna
captain my wrestling team a 190 pounds
wow yeah we're Jack oh yeah I could I
could totally kick some ass
all right I wanted to be protector of
the nerd set that's what I've got you
know what that makes sense with nothing
that was my superhero dream right they
being back then you know the tough
quarterbacks would be shoving nerds into
the locker room and then you would show
up before they would later learn that
you needed the nurse to fix your
computer right so everybody was
respected and revered in Revere it and
became the richest people in the world
right is the day where people would nerd
hunting I was card-carrying nerd and I
wanted to be the protector of all the
nerds of the world in my own little
superhero fantasy so yeah that's a noble
fan this song had been like a little bat
signal that'll go up in the sky and I
would land what would it be a pocket
protector they shot a pocket protector
of the day that would be like a slide
rule and robbery extended the slide
movers that's a that's a serious hey
account admit it necessary yes oh no I
study martial arts and so I was in my
day so somewhere below some layers of
fat a few those muscles I think might
still be there it's a muscle memory
maybe whatsoever okay I asked a trainer
I said so what am I to get my six-pack
yet you said it's still there it's just
under the fact right so I was jacked off
like 40 pounds ago and if I take it off
I can take them off by the end of this
year okay maybe but you know see if any
of your veins okay all right there you
go Gerald yeah there's a cool there's
your answer
yeah well what if you saw that the
shirts recently yeah I can still feel
shirt but but you generally I'm sitting
at a table and you'll see my belly
hanging oh I see my upper body not my
midsection now imma leave this alone
I've got a fully respectable middle-aged
man belly that I'm quite proud of it I
took Chuck will come back for the next
segment yes and you'll be here don't run
away I wanna add you're listening to
Startalk
we are back on Startalk neil degrasse
tyson shut nice sitting across from me
yes I am
Chuck you tweet Chuck nice comic that is
correct at Chuck nice I like your I like
when there's a in effect going on either
the Oscars or the Superbowl and she just
bought you throwing up bar yeah I do
then you like them you're like ninja
stars that's the only way I can get
through those I was like Katy Perry
survived yeah I during the Superbowl
halftime
all right so we are in cosmic queries
yes we are but Startalk the cosmic
queries addition I call it absolutely
absolutely yeah so what do you have so
we've got questions from all across the
internet I know I haven't seen them you
have not seen them and so let's get back
to our our our questions and this one is
from Jersey Norrington Jersey right
sounds like that sounds like an anchor
loose or porn more importantly an actor
gene origin or an anchor porn man a crow
porn Richard good evening I'm Jersey
Norrington your top story bout Wow Wow
Wow
okay bye so 1970 I know more music yes
all right with ya all right here we go
uh why is it that no one talks about
ITER this one puts ITER I never heard of
it so maybe he's right
maybe he's right but um they're trying
to get a fusion reactor to work so it
could create an infinite source of
energy I really think that's cool all
right so I turn let me to remember what
that stands for international
thermonuclear experimental
whether you are staying for I don't
remember reactor reactor thank you I'll
take feel aggression and so you can have
fusion right a fusion is to bring
together of smaller atoms right to make
a bigger atom it turns out when you do
that you get energy okay
up to a point but you get energy bring
two hydrogen atoms make helium you get
energy mmm the Sun does that every
second of its why sweet and it is very
efficient it really is it's just just
backup when okay turning a lot is good
so it takes high temperature okay and
you're fusing nuclei so thermo nuclear
fusion yeah that is what that's called
thermal nuclear fusion now we have
mastered thermonuclear fusion ever since
like the 50s
okay late 40s early 50s it's called a
bomb right what we have not mastered is
the control of thermonuclear fusion
right all right
uncontrolled thermonuclear fusion is
called a bomb now the stock no that was
they'll be oh no cuz that was the
hydrogel the no that was an atomic bomb
time using and Nagasaki used your that
one used catonian plutonium so where's
the hydrogen bomb hydrogen bomb has
never been used in warfare but those
pictures you see with like the tiny
little ships next to the whole and half
the ocean is yelling out of those are
hydrogen bonds
unlike hydra bombs make atom bombs look
like like starter firecrackers oh yeah
oh there's no contest between the two of
them oh yeah when we talk about nuclear
power we're really talking about who's
you know who's got what up you okay now
if your start the starter kit is to is
to make a nuclear fission bomb and
that's what happened in the Second World
War
okay so that's a nuclear fission buck
because you take big atoms make them
blue and get energy by doing a - exactly
yeah yeah so then the atomic bomb that
is big atoms in the very specific cases
of the Second World War
splitting uranium and plutonium okay but
element named after the cosmic object
Pluto by the way okay
uranium was named after the planet
Uranus and guess what neptunium was
named after oh the god of the sea that's
our three consecutive elements on it for
you
table uranium neptunium plutonium that's
named after Uranus Neptune and Pluto
misses Pluto's not a planet anymore I
think it got good got on the periodic
table on false pretense this between you
and me Gary started okay so now what are
they gonna call them appear either turn
Neil killed me
dwarf Pluto right so so dwarf tony i'm
Dorf Tommy there you go I love it sorry
so getting back to them about two-feet
fusion normal nuclear fuses Oh in France
there is a there's a collaborative
project international project to try to
harness fusion because if you did it and
harness it in the way the Sun does it in
a controlled way you have essentially an
unlimited supply of energy of course and
and as they say - chief - bill
personally I think our electricity is
already too cheap to bill you know what
right of course you do get electric bill
but you know it's too cheap to build why
if you're driving away from your home
and you see you left your living room
light on are you gonna stop the car get
out go unlock the door go in and turn
out the light no you know that light is
staying on until you get home today even
if you're a conservation even if you're
good you say no I'm not I'm a that's why
I got the old of and the fluorescent
lightbulbs okay so I got fluorescent
light so already we should get certainly
in America we treat the United States we
treat electricity like it is the least
of our financial right priorities given
how we use it so fully lit up malls at
night when nobody's there for totally
lit up buildings they'll light up silk
cities when everybody's going on
anybody's my home and it's a sweep so so
so this why is anyone talking about it
well we haven't achieved it yet the day
it's achieved its gonna be headlines all
over the place right yeah so do you
think it's achievable because I mean
that is real principle yeah you have to
control plasma here's the problem the
the temperature of the stuff you need to
it has to be high temperature device to
fuse the nuclei together as I stated
you're basically talking about having
the Sun here on earth exactly and it's
so hot you say okay
oh how what vessel you're going to put
it in and carry it from one place to
another
here take this 10 million degree plasma
right go straight home with it don't
know anywhere else right so their plasma
is actually
magnetically responsive so there are
things where you can create a magnetic
cavity where it kind of like a magnetic
bottle right he will and then it sort of
bounces off the magnetic field that
contains it kind of like the radiation
from the Sun does on the earth
well it sees the magnetic field and then
drills around it it's precisely the same
phenomenon going on okay but if you
design a magnetic bottle intelligently
then maybe you can have it serve your
energy needs by having fusion with it
fusion within it okay so so oh my god
let me tell you something listen and I'm
just the person gets very nervous and
Jersey Jersey all I can say man is this
sounds Jersey Wellington was Jersey
ignore ignore ingenuous anchor porn man
yes it sounds really dangerous well I
mean like it what you're talking about
if let's say you have this magnetic bomb
and the containment field fails oh you
are wiping out like I don't know what
yeah firm I don't know how many miles
around you so you design you design it
so it doesn't fail next question ah we
have so solved this problem that's why
you need really good engineers work
there you go man
all right what else you're okay here we
go let's move on to mmm Hersh von
Jurgens Vera longer Dunnsville okay keep
telling yourself that jerk I'm so glad
you're not president of a university
who's reading the names of the diplomas
oh man is happy life and next guy please
come up and get your diploma next guy
and young lady please come up and get
your diploma young lady
alright here we go I hear a dear dr.
Tyson okay I love when you talk about
the validity of science in movies one
thing that always divides my suspension
of disbelief in sci-fi movies is when
the character is briefly exposed to
space too
between airlocks without some sort of
space pressure-suit this happens in both
sunshine and event horizon is this even
remotely possible
thanks for entertaining me on my commute
mmm hey nurse that was cool very nice
okay so here's the problem when you
change the pressure that your body is
immersed in okay and we learn this I
think for the first time building the
Brooklyn Bridge oh really
yeah and building the Brooklyn Bridge a
lot of that structure is deep underwater
and so you each River do you have these
things called caissons I think they're
called and these are basically huge
bubbles that just a if you have a I
don't take like a pot okay all right and
then invert it and then submerge the pot
right you've you've trapped air in there
yes you did so you can little chairs
inside that pot because hot big enough
so you can sit in it inverted and then
you submerge the entire pot and now you
can breathe the air while you're
underwater okay but the deeper you go
under the water the higher is the
pressure pushing up against that air
right from the water that's at your feet
okay the higher is that pressure and
that can have an effect on your
physiology all right and that when they
did this to build the Brooklyn Bridge
they discovered this new physiological
failure called the bends uh-huh and what
happens is you can go down there that's
fine but it's coming back gases that are
dissolved in your circulatory system
when your body is then exposed to lesser
pressure begin to escape from you okay
and the gases in your lungs as they
expand you can just exhale that all
right cool okay but suppose the gases
dissolved in your bloodstream
most of these pockets of air show up
inside your bloodstream that's not good
isn't that's not good yeah thanks for
concluding that's not good that's not
good so you have to be very careful when
you change from one pressure to the
other entity was slowly or
non-catastrophic lee all right so if you
go from one atmospheric pressure into
zero atmospheric pressure space
right you're subject to these things
that could end up giving you the bends
but if you're not there for very long
generally you're not there longer than
you can breathe okay
right right how long are you in the
airlock for a half hour no you're in the
airlock without a suit on because that
was some emergency maneuver you had to
do you're not going to be there longer
than you can hold your breath correct
all right so uh all yet you might get
some the case of the bends but it's not
going to kill your eyes are not gonna
pop out okay you know why your eyes are
not gonna pop out quizzes on an air cup
there's not an air pocket behind them
ready to pop out your eyes we're liquid
all right so when liquid changes
pressure it's all about whether the gas
is doing within them okay okay now what
an example of gases coming out of liquid
yeah oh do tell believe me cuz I could
think of a few died is when you go into
I'm eight years old brain exactly so so
what the best example is a sealed can of
soda okay it's under pressures under
pressure right and and let's say let's
take a bottle so you can look at it it's
under pressure you'll see bubbles
anywhere
pop the lid all the bubbles escape
exactly they were dissolved there until
the pressure change exact and so it's
whatever is the atmospheric pressure in
it then it goes down to hemispheric
pressure the bubbles escape so so if you
have to be careful and it won't be
comfortable but just get the hell out of
there so now okay if I'm in the airlock
and then the event horizon this ship
okay okay
depressurize yeah I'm in it yeah you got
some you gotta you gotta but all I have
now is I held my breath yes the airlock
opens huh and now just across I can push
off and get into another airlock
repressurize could I do that yes he's
okay easily okay if you have your wits
about you have your wits about you but
you could be know that which is now now
that's my home movie you are you ain't
making it that's the real movie right
there that's how big with actual right
just like the airlock opens up just like
but you couldn't hear because I'm in
space exactly because it's racing all we
can hear you just screaming air oh yeah
exactly it would be silent movie that'd
be funny the camera picks up the most
violent scream and yes that's super cool
this is something they did accurately in
the movie gravity look the sound level
as they went in and out of airlocks
would go from complete dead to slowly
you begin to hear it and then it was a
full volume sound they did it
brilliantly yeah I'm happy gravity yes
so that so there you listen there earth
uh yeah that's a great answer man that
was very very cool it's all about the
gas baby good and in the movie one of
the Mars movies which one the one that
had named one of the Mars but
read plan and uh it was either red
planet or mission to Mars I think was
mission to Mars okay uh where the tether
doesn't reach him and he doesn't want
them to come after him so he did he he
so he kills himself right with it they
don't come back you know he kills
himself he lifts off cuz lying yeah okay
and three seconds later he looked like
he's been dead for 20 years right no
that doesn't know you would see him
suffocating there right that's how
really it would happen yes or or Total
Recall where Arnold Schwarzenegger
doesn't have his helmet on huh and his
eyes begin to bulge out of his head like
one of those little squeeze toys I've
seen those yes and pressure relieving
you know the dress for me the squeeze
toy and that's what his eyes do yeah
he's like how are you close great no
that wasn't even a sentence what you
knew it could only be uttered by awesome
so yeah how'd you pull it off well you
know does brilliant yeah that's that's
like every comics like every comic does
Arnold uh II and that's how you have to
do to do are not how you did but uh so
that's not true then that that's the you
can survive a couple of minutes for a
couple minutes yes okay yes just don't
stay there long that's all
gotcha
got it if our circulatory system were
entirely gas right and then you stepped
out into an extremely low pressure
environment yeah you'll explode like a
balloon
yeah boy you're just remember we're
liquid and so liquid has different
reactions so there's different
properties for liquid and a fact that
we're 70 percent of that boom
right no no we're a hundred one hundred
percent over nothing but you're setting
yourself water that's what I mean yes
except there's some water yeah but did
right yeah look on this liquid you could
is bone considered liquid in your body
sure no I'm serious God where are we
just a specular is bone liquid well my
question just come out of your mouth
yeah because you said we're all liquid
we gotta go to commercial so I can slap
you upside your head man and then bring
you back that just shows how much I
trust you man listening to our talk
radio but the cosmic queries Edition
potpourri we'll be right back
we are back star talk radio Neil
deGrasse Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist Chuck nice yes Saracen
across from me yes I am Chuck I
bitch-slapped you over the commercial
break yes pretty asking are our bows
liquid no nope no bones are not liquid
what I was saying is like it I thought
maybe there was some way that you
considered them to be a liquid because
you know you have marrow in a bone which
is kind of gelatinous you know what I
mean it's not completely solid I don't
know that's not like a complete like
trying to make up for that no so so what
the real question is if you took all the
liquid out of a human body how much
weight remains in calcium in the bones
or the muscle fibers whatever I don't
know what that number is
okay yeah yeah that's what I was trying
to say yeah right you know all right
cool we're cool uh just before we begin
this just came across my desk yes here
just in a couple people submitted geek
pickup lines right but I kind of lame
I'll read them okay but they're kind of
lame but I'm wondering maybe we should
actually have an actual contest
I like the idea and then we get to read
if you and we pick the best ones and
read them on the air all right
devote a whole show I was gonna say
whole show that's a very ambitious
that's ambition America Heroes one I'll
do my best Barry White okay are you the
square root of negative one because you
can't be real
Oh actually that's not too bad it's
actually not two but you gotta like beat
you got to remember you're like
imaginary numbers square root of
negative one um this is totally like
calculus geek I wish I was your
derivative so I couldn't I wish I was
your derivative so I could like tangent
to your curves
that's like calculus okay how are you
finding the slope of a line yeah exactly
that's what the derivative is and so you
take the first river of a curve right
like you live right there right there
comes across that right there I have one
more here
back up operating our live is like
dividing by zero you cannot define it oh
I gotta tell you using those lines you
better build a robot girl here's one uh
hey baby oh you graviton cuz I find
myself attracted to you totally get that
oh I bet I bet our our listeners could
totally beat these and so we got to
figure out how to announce the contest
yeah we'll do it on a website we'll
figure it out yeah and we'll do a whole
show it's not only part of a show yeah
let some people get in there then you
know there's probably better than that
all right so what do you have all right
let's get back to our cosmic queries
potpourri potpourri um what sir let's
let's see let's see what Jim Scarborough
wants to move hmm Jim says what is this
conservation of information demske puts
forth why do I keep forgetting things
okay this is good are you that's a great
question is it really yeah so
information it in the in the middle 20th
century and onward and people the whole
branch of research open a call
information theory trilled right if
something has information how long will
it retain that information and if it
doesn't have the information where did
the information go okay information is
very different from things like
conservation of mass or energy or mass
energy for example if you have an orange
and then I give you a second orange you
have twice as much orange don't you I
hope so okay
if I give you a newspaper then I give
you that identical newspaper you do not
have twice as much information that is
true you're the same amount of
information by duplicating but I do have
a bathroom for my dog and now I do hope
it's a puppy you know it's a bus it's an
infirm dog so information theory behaves
differently from other kind I'm sorry
conservation of it for me
is a different understanding at a
different treatment of information than
conservation of mass energy would be
treated that's all and so there's an
idea that can you lose information what
happens to it and he's saying if there's
a conservation of information theorem
then why is it that he forgets stuff
right no it's a good it's a brilliant
question um what happens is what you
remember it or thought you remember
becomes other things typically okay
right right just becomes other things
and so so it's still there it's just
such a sec it's not the same in France a
man makes a total amount of information
yeah it's an amount of information you
might be conserving there but it's not
my research specialty so I don't know
what the latest is that they're all
saying about it right it seems to me
that if I have a newspaper and I burn it
I got rid of all that information true
and this is what happens in book
burnings civilizations typically take a
few steps back because they've lost and
when you say civilizations you mean
Republicans no I'm joking
no you don't I do you don't I do you
don't well Jim there you have it there
is a there really is a conservation of
information and by the way everyone who
passed the Jim Crow laws were Democrat
this is true as a reminder we yes
Southern Democrats we all know are now
modern-day Republicans but you can't
generalize over time and space I'll give
you that yeah all right Jim great
question and your answer is early onset
Alzheimers oh sorry
all right let's uh let's uh let's move
on let's okay I'm gonna see here with
Wow Wow okay
real simple but have we join in in this
Wow
okay yes it did admire the question and
leave us leave us hanging okay this is
Jacob Seymour and Jacob wants to know
does nuclear fusion occur at the bottom
of black holes ooh yeah I was like wow
wow really simple but good question yeah
it's pause as possible okay because at
the singularity which is like the limits
of Einstein's equations where in fact
you are literally dividing by zero right
which means we don't have a theory to
understand the singularity we can just
say look this wall but that's the best
we got
what was something better right at that
singularity right at that point all
matter is at a very dense state but we
do know that the energy created by
nuclear fusion right even if it occurred
at the singularity would not be enough
to do a damn thing to the black hole Wow
black holes are stronger than any
nuclear fusion that would occur within
them so even run note you can run that
it's why we got the black hole in the
first place Michael used to be a star
right and the star was going to explode
and it didn't the Michael said no you're
not so so as the massive stars the
higher the mass star the difference
their fate becomes more and more
different from what the Sun would be
there's a point where a star dies as an
explosion a supernova it was more
massive than that it wants to become a
supernova but the gravity overcomes that
it is black hole gravity and the whole
star collapses down and implodes within
itself and so no you can't great time I
try to get out thank you pulling me back
again that is what everyone is saying
who's stuck in 100 Wow with that level
of frustration I'm sure from look I'm so
sure when I was fascinating yeah good
stuff good stuff there all right let's
go with Douglas Napolitano and Douglas
says wait you pronounce his names in a
Spanish way there's clearly Italian an
epilogue on not put it on oh come on now
put it on I pull it down okay Douglas
wants to know this if I keeps from nuit
I mean from where name next yeah mm-hmm
doubles was to notice was there space
before the Big Bang
or was space created during the Big Bang
what is the universe expanding into in
other words is space expanding with the
matter of energy or is the matter
energy expanding into space man my head
man my boy that's like cosmic angst
going on yes in the suite yo know I
gotta tell you it's it's a nice little
uh conundrum teddy yep
so everything that we've come to know
and define space to be was formed within
the Big Bang okay and if we have a
multiverse or some prior existing state
out of which our universe spawned that
would be embedded in higher dimensions
and so normal space is not how you would
address that that configuration the
higher dimensional space of four
dimensional space five or ten dimensions
it's some higher dimensional space in
which that occurs that's so we're so if
space is where there's nothing then
outside of space you might call that
nothing nothing nothing nothing but
perhaps so we have top people working on
the nothing nothing that's that's it so
truck chuck we are in the five minute
warning zone this means you don't that
means
that's right lightning round it's the
lightning round okay I will answer
questions in sound bite mode okay get in
as many as we can in the next four
minutes all right here we go this one
from Facebook and Paul beare Paul beare
wants to know how is the gravity of the
Sun strong enough to hold Jupiter into
place but not strong enough to pull the
earth close enough to eat it uh-oh
because earth is moving faster than
Jupiter and at our speed at our distance
we are in a safe orbit if we were moving
at the speed of Jupiter at our speed I
had our distance right now we would fall
into the into the Sun boom bada bing mmm
bottom oh oh yeah yeah
okay all right so every orbit and every
distance from the Sun there is one speed
right that you can sustain and maintain
that orbit anything less you fall into
the Sun anything more you'll go to fly
out you'll [ __ ] go to a higher orbit
okay well good at it all right here we
go
also from Facebook Patrick Clark wants
to know this dr. Tyson what do you see
as the advantages benefits of permanent
human colonization of other bodies in
the solar system what resources do
places like the moon and any A's hold
and how could we harness and use them
efficiently Oh so nASA has a whole new
branch of itself called I
is are you okay Institute resource
utilization which is NASA speak for when
you get there find your own damn food
damn man rough so you got to look at his
their water their is their natural
resources can you can you see the soils
in a way to grow plant life
is there enough sunlight so right now
there's nothing like Earth out there and
so if you're gonna go you have to bring
a whole lot of Cheetos with something to
keep you fed until you so the resource
we developed our species exist on earth
thriving on researches resources that
are native to earth right that's why we
are okay here right and not okay on the
moon or on Mars so this is a huge
challenge there you go we have not yet
resolved go next all right there you
have it the answer is click your heels
Patrick there's no place like home
alright uh let's see them I mean Patrick
is wearing ruby slippers all right
Amanda Dean wants to know this uh why
are some planets in gas form and some in
solid does this differ in a binary star
system Oh turns out would you say Earth
Day is gaseous no because it's mostly
rock and then we have this thin layer of
atmosphere on Jupiter if you go deep
enough it has a solid middle oh yeah
yeah everybody's got a solid core so
basically we're all the same it's just
more atmosphere atmosphere and in
chippers case most of his mass is in the
form of gas I got a fever and I need
more atmosphere more cowbell hot must
real all right here's the best arresting
this is from oh by the way Jupiter has a
much higher gravity so it can hold the
very light gases such as hydrogen and
helium that we could not hold Jupiter is
mostly hydrogen a dealing very like
acids very fast-moving atoms they can
fly out of a weak gravity field as they
did for us yeah yeah so our atmosphere
is denser heavier than Jupiter's
atmosphere we have heavier molecules in
our atmosphere Oh cuz they don't move as
fast instead it'll sound like a chipmunk
on Jupiter on Jupitus you so would yes I
never thought that through cuz I was not
going to think I would get out of my
spaceship and open my
while I was manager Jewett but since
you've already thought this through
Chuck that is exactly how what happened
talk one more question and it beats him
so all the Jupiter Ian's are or it sound
like Mickey Mouse got the native Jerry
all right here we go this from Paul AB
Paul F Aaron Proms Aaron ski jr. okay
how can we tell what bar our planets and
the other objects are made of whoo yeah
this was at birth of modern astrophysics
in the late 19th century we took the
spectroscope the prism take light moving
through the prison at the other side it
breaks it up into a component colors and
of like a rainbow right in there you
find embedded the fingerprints of the
very chemical identity of what it is you
are looking at boom bada bing it's so
today we don't just look at pretty
pictures of the nice guy as Hubble would
have you believe looking at the greatest
hits from that telescope what we do is
we take the light and we slice it and we
dice it and in that light we find carbon
nitrogen oxygen so look at carbon
dioxide carbon monoxide we find
molecules atoms and that is how we
decode the chemical nature of the
universe
Chuck we gotta go thanks for being with
me on another edition of Startalk this
the cosmic queries edition my pleasure
potpourri okay you've been listening to
start-up radio as always I'm your host
Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist needing you to keep
looking up this is Startalk